For decades, human beings have played games against computers.
At first, the computers struggled.
But then, they started winning.
Watson!
What is Creed?
Yes!
And now they've become so dominant that they're raising doubts about the future of humanity.
The latest emblem for existential dread is Google's DeepMind project,...
...which created AlphaGo,...
...an AI program that's become unbeatable at the most complex strategy game on the planet.
While the game of checkers has 10 to the power of 20 possible outcomes,...
...and a game of chess has 10 to the power of 40 possible outcomes,...
...Go has 10 to the power of 80 possible outcomes.
AlphaGo is trained to analyze situations itself,....
...by breaking the game down to tiny parts and visualizing all possible moves.
It played the world's best Go player, 19-year-old Ke Jie,...
...with the help of a human handler.
AlphaGo beat him three times and after doing what it was designed to do,...
...retired from the game.
If a system like AlphaGo can learn all the moves in Go well enough to beat a person,...
...then it has the potential to replace lawyers and accountants, among dozens of other jobs.
It might be perfect, but it has no way to navigate human politics.